STEPHANIE WONG: The
flexibility of Kubeflow
lets you run your ML jobs
anywhere you can run Kubernetes
and gives you an entire
platform to work with.
Sometimes you don't need the
entire Kubeflow platform,
but you still want to use
pipelines to orchestrate
machine learning workflows.
Let's look at Cloud AI Platform
Pipelines, a Google Cloud
service that lets you
focus even more on your ML
and less on your infrastructure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you want to
read more about how
to run Pipelines
on Google Cloud,
check out the
documentation link below.
Previously, I talked about how
to work with Pipelines as part
of a Kubeflow deployment, but
we can use Cloud AI Platform
Pipelines to get the
same user interface
and back-end functionality.
If you don't need
the rest of Kubeflow
and are just looking for the
ability to work with pipelines,
Cloud AI Platform
gives you a quick way
to set up an installation.
On top of that, authentication
with other Google Cloud
services is built in.
This lets you focus on
building your pipeline
and integrating with
other Cloud services
without needing to manage
a complex deployment.
Let's start by getting a
Pipelines installation set up.
To try it out, head to
the Google Cloud console
and use the left navigation
to find Pipelines
under AI Platform.
Then click the New
Instance button.
Google Cloud will set
up a Kubernetes cluster
and then deploy the Pipeline
installation on top of it,
but all the details
are handled for you.
Once it's set up
and running, you'll
have the full Pipelines UI
and SDK to start working with.
We'll go back to
the Pipelines page
and click Open Pipelines
Dashboard to get
to the same user interface.
We can see experiments and
runs here, as well as look
at our metadata and artifacts.
Don't forget to check out the
previous metadata management
episode, which goes into
more detail about it.
So it's still possible to
upload a compiled pipeline
through the same user interface,
but what if you're using
a notebook for your model?
Here's where we can use another
service to help us out--
Cloud AI Platform Notebooks.
In our previous
videos, we've talked
about the advantages of
running a notebook in the cloud
rather than on
your local machine.
Cloud AI Platform
Notebooks gives you
a simple way to do just that.
You can create a new
notebook quickly and jump
into a JupyterLab interface.
Back in the Google
Cloud console,
just click New Instance,
and choose an environment.
Since we're working with
a TensorFlow 1 example,
we'll choose TensorFlow
1.1.5 without any GPUs
and hit Create.
Once again, all of
the infrastructure
is taken care of
behind the scenes,
and we're able to just
click Open JupyterLab to get
to our interface, where we can
create notebooks and execute
them.
Since we're using the same
notebook from the last video,
we've already cloned the
same repository here.
Code for Pipelines is
made to be reusable
so we don't need
to change anything
to create an execution.
We will need to specify the same
properties-- our Google Cloud
project and the Cloud
Storage bucket where
our model will be stored.
There's one more
change we need to make.
We have to tell the pipeline's
SDK where our pipeline's
endpoint is located.
This is as easy as copying the
URL of our hosted pipeline,
which we can get by clicking
Settings next to a pipeline
and storing it as a
variable in our notebook.
Since the same user created both
the notebook and the pipeline's
installation, the authentication
is taken care of for us.
We'll then modify the line
where we execute the pipeline
and point it to the server
and then run the notebook.
Other than that, this
is the same pipeline,
so we'll still be
using the Cloud AI
platform to do the training
and serving of the model.
We're just doing it from
a different environment.
Cloud AI platforms
can be an easy way
to get a pipelines environment
without having to set up
an entire Kubeflow deployment.
In addition, it's easy to
integrate with other Google
Cloud services to help
extend your ML projects,
like hosting notebooks,
model training, and serving.
Try it out for yourself.
[MUSIC PLAYING]